wir kommen zur sternstunde religion
heute geht es bei uns um die
skrupellosen brutalen morde von dresden
paris nizza und in jeder anschlag macht
aufs neue fassungslos einen täter lehrer
bei paris ein erstochene homosexueller
in dresden getötete gläubige in nizza
erschossene passanten in wien frankreich
österreich und deutschland ja ganz
westeuropa befindet sich im fadenkreuz
islamistischer terroristen
deshalb wollen die länder auch eine
gemeinsame antwort auf die ständige
bedrohung finden
an der heutigen multinationalen video
konferenz stellt die deutsche kanzlerin
aber eines von vornherein klar es geht
hier nicht darüber waren wir uns auch
einig um eine auseinandersetzung
zwischen dem islam und dem christentum
zum beispiel sondern es geht darum dass
das demokratische gesellschaftsmodell
sich mit terroristischen und
antidemokratischen verhalten
auseinandersetzen muss und das tut man
von berlin über wien bis nach paris der
französische präsident legt sein
hauptaugenmerk wie erwartet auf die
außengrenzen der eu können unsere
binnengrenzen nicht länger offen halten
wenn wir die regeln des schengen raums
nicht grundlegend überarbeiten
wir müssen schengen reformieren damit es
ein raum der sicherheit werde juri dem
österreichischen kanzler machen die
tausenden heimgekehrten dschihadisten
sorgen
viele würden im gefängnis sitzen aber
bald entlassen werden
das sind tickende zeitbomben und wenn
wir unser aller freiheit schützen wollen
dann müssen wir die freiheit dieser
menschen einschränken
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen setzt einen akzent auf die
inklusion das beste mittel die schärfste
waffe gegen jede form von extremismus
ist für junge menschen perspektiven
haben um lösungen gegen den
gewalttätigen islamistischen extremismus
zu finden muss man das phänomen und
seine ursachen besser verstehen
dazu möchten wir in dieser runde
beitragen bei mir zu gast sind reinhard
schulze islamwissenschaftler cornelia
bessler forensische psychiaterin wo im
loser jugendsozialarbeiter und
zugeschaltet aus wien ist uns muss alpha
die audi radikalisierung experte und
religionspädagoge herzlich willkommen
ihnen allen in seinem ersten statement
nach den attentaten von wien äußerte
sich der österreichische bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz folgendermaßen wir werden
diesen hass keinen raum geben denn unser
feind das sind niemals alle angehörigen
einer religionsgemeinschaft unser
vereinter sind niemals alle menschen die
aus einem bestimmten land kommen nein
unser feind das sind die extremisten und
terroristen
herr die auch diese doch sehr
vorsichtige formulierung von sebastian
kurz erweckten ein schein anscheinend
dass man nicht alle muslime da
inkludieren will
wie ist dieses statement bei den
österreichischen muslimen den angekommen
in österreich leben geschätzt 700.000
muslimische menschen der seine
heterogene gruppe also kein homogener
block und genau das ist das was die
terroristen die unter extremisten auf
allen seiten aber propagieren wollen das
ist nämlich ein wir und die anderen gibt
und dass es homogene gruppen sind die
man dann eben versucht durch solche
terroristische aktionen gegeneinander
aufzuwiegeln aufzuhetzen quasi die
gesellschaft in einer art bürgerkrieg zu
stürzen deswegen war es sehr wichtig
dass der bundeskanzler festgehalten hat
es gibt eine isolierte ideologisch
extremistische gruppe und das ist die
auf die wir unser augenmerk legen müssen
um gegen dieses phänomen vor zu gehen
sonst spielt man nämlich das spiel der
extremisten mit die wie gesagt ein
zerwürfnis innerhalb der gesellschaft
provozieren wollen
worin lucia wie kommen denn diese
statements bei ihnen an wir haben ja
auch von angela merkel und von der leyen
gehört so eine gewisse differenzierung
die wir in den letzten jahren vielleicht
vermisst haben
ist das bei ihnen auch so angekommen
vor allem denke ich das ist eine sehr
spannender ansatz um überhaupt dann auch
darauf aufmerksam zu machen was sind
endlich integrierte dann seid ihr es gab
auch unterschiedliche statements von
help sebastian kurz und eines das dann
auch sehr stark geblieben ist und auch
sehr viel zum nachdenken ist ist auch
der begriff des politischen islam
die r welches er möchte als auch als
straftatbestand zu kurz er werde darüber
werden wir im verlauf der sendung sicher
noch sprechen und ich denke das ist das
sind dann begriffe die bei den muslimen
bei den jungen muslimen aus auf sehr
viel unverständnis auch wirken und aber
auch dann auch eine gewisse ohnmacht an
wo kann man ansetzen wie soll wird und
dass man das problem dann in dieser
richtung nur einseitig dann ansieht also
es gibt eine entwicklung in der rhetorik
frau besser es gibt aber auch eine
entwicklung in den taten an sich also
die haben eine enthauptung wir haben das
durchtrennen der kehle
wir haben brutalste arten die menschen
ermordet werden was für rückschlüsse
ziehen sie aus der art und weise wie
diese morde vonstatten gingen die boote
sind brutal wie sie das erwähnt haben
es ist aber jetzt nicht ganz was neues
sondern wir haben die enthauptungen
schon während den auseinandersetzungen
in syrien gesehen wo der islamische
staat sehr viel territorium gewonnen hat
und auch seine macht ausgedehnt hat es
ist eher so ein wärter syndrom das heißt
eine nachahmung das ist unsere art macht
zu demonstrieren
und ich möchte noch kurz was zu den
äußerungen sagen von merkel kurz und
fand allein
ich finde es ein sehr wichtiger und
kluger ansatz weil ist die gefahr
impliziert mit solchen
auseinandersetzung dass es eben eine
spaltung gibt und einen bürgerkrieg und
es geht darum dass wir diese situation
vermeiden
und insbesondere und seine
demokratischen grundwerte schützen in
unserer gesellschaft und die die das
angreifen klar definieren und auch
diesbezüglich vorgehen
mich interessiert das noch etwas genauer
zu verstehen welche art der spaltung ist
da eigentlich gemeint wenn auch die
politiker immer davon sprechen dass sie
diese spaltung die die terroristen auf
diese aktien quasi nicht zulassen würden
von was für einer teilung in der
gesellschaft gehen dann politiker dabei
aus herr schulz ich denke die politiker
haben eine vorstellung es gebe eine
muslimische mehrheits gemeinschaft die
relativ ein konsens bild dahingehend
dass sie mit dem terrorismus nichts zu
tun hat und auf der anderen seite dann
die terroristen die mit der
mehrheitsgesellschaft der muslime nichts
zu tun habe so dass eine differenzierung
zwar augenblick augenscheinlich wird und
man sieht auch diese differenzierung ja
in der praxis aber ich denke dass es
nicht ausreicht diese differenzierung
vorzunehmen sondern es müsste eine ganz
klare ansage gemacht werden wer denn
eigentlich wirklich dieser dieser
terrorismus ist wenn er repräsentiert
welche ideen welche vorstellungswelten
tragen die sind der ort muss damit auch
für die muslimische mehrheit gemeinde
klar wird dass sie nicht als eine art
von hinterhof dieses terrorismus
interpretiert werden aus dem immer
wieder auch neue terroristen erwachsen
könnten sondern dass sie auch so eine
ganz klare grenze gezogen wird auch in
den köpfen auch in den köpfen der
gemeinde angehörigen auch in den köpfen
der öffentlichkeit so dass dadurch auch
besser erkennbar wird wer denn
eigentlich wirklich die gegner dieser
demokratischen ausländer geblieben ist
kann man das so genau benennen also wenn
wenn man das rhetorisch umsetzen will
und das so genau benennen will dann muss
vorausgesetzt werden dass diese klarheit
gedanklich schon erst mal verzogen ist
kann man denn diese gruppe so genau
benennen
das also man draußen aus der
wissenschaftlichen perspektive ist das
nicht so problematisch das problem ist
dass in der öffentlichen meinungsbildung
labels und fachbegriffe gewählt werden
die selbst schnell zu erklären scheinen
um wen es sich handelt man nehme den
begriff die politischen islam
niemann begriff islamismus der plötzlich
eine bestimmte vorstellungswelt
generiert der aber inhaltlich praktisch
nichts aus sagt man müsste also schon
sehr viel mehr und sehr viel genauer
hinschauen wer denn wirklich diese ideen
stiftende vorstellungswelt ist die dann
diesen terrorismus mit generiert ich
möchte noch mal auf das problem der
spaltung zurückkommen wir machen jetzt
gerade in diesen letzten jahren und
besonders in diesem jahr ganz stark die
erfahrung dass es ganz starke
spaltungstendenzen in unseren
gesellschaften gibt abgesehen von einem
islamistischen hintergrund ich nenne die
praxis abstimmung in großbritannien die
us wahlen die wii gerade kürzlich erlebt
haben und auch die korona pandemien
scheint eine massive spaltung als thema
zu erzeugen in unserer gesellschaft frau
besser leben wir ganz allgemein in einer
zeit der spaltung und der
radikalisierung würde vielleicht das
fällen bis auf touren und sagen wir
leben in einer zeit wo verunsicherung
sich breit macht es ist eine
verunsicherung auf verschiedensten
ebenen einerseits betreffend unserer
natur umweltverschmutzung andererseits
gesellschaftspolitisch wir haben
verschiedenste schwierige diskussionen
in welcher gesellschaftsform leben wir
haben auseinandersetzung aber auch
ökonomisch im rahmen von
umweltkatastrophen und von leuten die
schwerst betroffen sind wir haben eine
verunsicherung betreffend
flüchtlingsströme wie gehen wir damit um
wo sich überforderung ausbreitet und da
ist natürlich die der suche nach einem
rettenden anker
rein psychologisch psychiatrisch sehr
schnell da und diese situation ist
geeignet für spaltungen weil dann
einzelne ideen ein
ausbreitung hat ohne dass man
differenziert sich damit
auseinandersetzen was geht es jetzt hier
eben auch die diskussion um den
politischen islam auch da ist haben wir
sehr viel verschiedenen ströme und ist
nicht jeder täter ist in einen topf zu
werfen sondern wir haben ganz viele
verschiedene biografien die dann zu
gleichen verhaltensweisen oder ähnliche
verhaltensweisen führen wohin lucia sie
sind jugendsozialarbeiter sie haben viel
mit problemfällen sozusagen sozialen
problemen zu tun nicht explizit
muslimischen problemfällen und sie
engagieren sich aber auch innerhalb der
muslimischen gemeinschaft für fragen der
integration des interreligiösen dialogs
sie haben vor einigen jahren mitgeholfen
eine ein projekt nämlich die swiss
muslims tores aufzuziehen eine reihe von
kurzclips in denen junge muslime über
ihre befindlichkeit ihrer identität
sprechen
was war die absicht dieses projektes
wenn man beispielsweise die studie ich
würde gern da meiner überleitung machen
vom ettinger von der universität zürich
anschaut dann hat die berichterstattung
der medien über muslime analysiert und
der teil wo gelingende integration und
der alltag der muslime ausmacht ist je 2
prozent der andere teil das sind dann
radikalisierung themen oder dort wo der
islam in einem negativen diskurs zur
pause auch präsentiert wird und unsere
absicht war einerseits mit einer
kurzfilm kampagne wo wir den alltag
junger muslime in der schweiz die sich
aus auch als schweizer und
schweizerinnen auch fühlen hier
integriert sind ihren alltag zu zu
dokumentieren und diese das projekt hat
zwei ziele einerseits auch etwas gegen
den an die muslimischen rassismus zu
machen indem man versucht stereotypen
und vorurteile abzubauen sie zu
dekonstruieren
aber auf der anderen seite auch opfer
native sie auch solche ideologien sehr
gerne generieren auch versuchen dort zu
thematisieren das heißt
nicht in nicht gegen narrativen ziel
sondern alternative narrativen dass das
geht so
wir haben uns entschieden ein video so
weil diese porträt zu machen indem wir
die über die herausforderung von jungen
muslimen dort reden aber auch
veranschaulichen wollen wie wie kann man
auch bewältigungsstrategien für diese
herausforderungen beispielsweise für
sich selber erarbeiten und sie haben wir
versucht in kurzvideos darzustellen herr
die auch sie haben bei ihren studien sie
arbeiten mit teilweise mit inhaftierten
straftätern die einen dschihadistischen
hintergrund haben hat einen
islamistischen hintergrund haben
zusammen sie haben verschiedene studien
gemacht und bei einer studie fiel mir
auch auf dass das thema der fehlenden
repräsentanz in den medien und in der
gesellschaft generell von einem teil
dieser inhaftierten auch beklagt wurde
und dass sie sich sozusagen als opfer
auch betrachten als teil innerhalb der
muslimischen gemeinschaft können sie uns
etwas darüber sagen was die erfahrung
der ausgrenzung mit menschen machten wie
das möglicherweise auf radikalisierung
einwirkt ganz wichtig ist dass die
verschiedenen extremistischen ideologien
die online und offline präsent sind und
auf unsere klienten in den
justizvollzugsanstalten eingewirkt haben
deswegen sicher wegen terroristischer
vereinigung verurteilt worden sind
die wahrnehmung dass man sozusagen zu
einer gruppe gehört die marginalisiert
ist die diskriminiert wird die
ausgegrenzt wird die weltweit bekämpft
wird persönliche erfahrungen subjektive
erfahrungen aber auch das was sie
gefiltert wahrnehmen doch ihre
propaganda kanäle also das was sozusagen
weltgeschehen und nachrichten ausmacht
ist etwas was die propaganda verstärkt
ausbreitet und immer wieder die negativ
rolle versucht darzulegen und sagt die
einzigen die etwas dazu tun können oder
in der lage sind dagegen zu handeln sind
wir unsere exklusive gruppe wir sind
ein besseres system zu schaffen und
gleichzeitig wird auch immer der hass
gegen die anderen gefördert in diesem
falle der hass gegen die
mehrheitsgesellschaft also die sie
umgebende gesellschaft sei es die
schweiz frankreich deutschland oder
österreich
also das ist das was auffällt also wenn
man sich die erste studie anschaut mit
25 personen die alle wegen
terroristische vereinigung angeklagt
oder verurteilt waren da spielt das
marginalisiert seien eine rolle und ganz
wichtig ist das gilt für alle fälle und
das aus unserer sicht auf das
hauptproblem dass die extremistische
ideologie genau dieses
auseinanderdriften der gesellschaft
propagiert und immer wieder verstärkt
also insofern das was auch vorhergesagt
wurde
alternative erzählungen oder auch gegen
erzählungen die dieses wir und die
anderen konterkarieren ist wichtig in
der präventionsarbeit aber dann später
auch in der die radikal easy rung arbeit
mit diesen personen die auch tatsächlich
schon straffällig geworden sind
herr schulze sehen sie das ähnlich dass
das aufbauen eines gegen maria tiefs ein
zentrales mittel ist ist sicherlich ein
sehr wichtiges mittel 1 1 gegen nativ
muss aber also wie er durch das auch
gesagt hatte nicht das alte bild was
auch in den dschihadistischen medien
verbreitet wird als auch nur neu
benennen neu in meine neue bedeutungen
ein zu schaffen
es gibt manche filme diese angebliche
der radikalisierung prozesse beschreiben
sollen wo der gleiche partners verwendet
wird der von dschihadisten verwendet
wird und man kann kein nicht sozusagen
eine partners mit athos bekämpfen man
kann man muss eigentlich versuchen ein
bild ein alternatives bild von
islamische sein islamischen dasein
kreieren das nicht darauf beruht sich
als wiedergänger des propheten mohammed
zu interpretieren sondern sozusagen als
lebendes jetzt in der gesellschaft
beheimatetes wesen zu interpretieren und
diese interpretation die dann auch der
islam stützen kann
die steht eigentlich im vordergrund und
weniger sozusagen die rekonstruktion
eines positiv gemeinten pathos eines
gelungenen guten muslims in der
vergangenheit einen interessanten ansatz
bietet amid c die vom schweizerischen
zentrum für islam und gesellschaft an
der universität fribourg an
er sagt nämlich man solle den
islamistischen extremismus nicht als
eine eigenständige kategorie betrachten
sondern müsse ihn vielmehr als teil des
rechtsextremen spektrums verstehen
werden sie das aus ihrer arbeit und
erfahrung auch so deuten protestler
[Musik]
das ist vielleicht die ich müsste noch
mehr gegen den ausführungen von ihm
haben wie er das findet ich finde es ist
extremismus per se kann verschiedene
inhalte bemühen das kann
rechtsextremismus aber gerade so gut
linksextremist das kann irgend eine
andere idee sein wie abtreibungsverbot
oder sonst es geht um die extremistische
haltung das heißt wir und die anderen
wir sind die besseren wir haben die
wahrheit das ist dieses diese spaltung
definition in die das mal liegt
impliziert das heißt es findet keine
differenzierte auseinandersetzung mehr
statt
und das ist nach meiner meinung das
zentrale moment es geht darum wieder in
diskurs zu kommen in dialog zu kommen um
den menschen zur autonomie zu führen
damit er reflektieren kann die welche
gesellschaft in welcher form wollen wir
zusammen leben und dann kann ich wieder
mit mich mit der mit ihm
auseinandersetzen
die negative sind ein teil aber nicht
alles eine weitere these möchte ich zur
diskussion stellen nämlich von hier
gefällt dem französischen soziologen der
sagt es hätte sich in gewissen
französischen großstädten so etwas wie
eine jihadistische grundstimmung breit
gemacht er spricht da von einem
dschihadisten atmosphäre hätten würden
sie etwas ähnliches für die
österreichischen städte beschreiben was
zumindest auf 214 sichtbar also dieses
phänomen ist bei uns hätten 90er 1990 er
jahren aufgeschlagen war es in
verbindung mit der auseinandersetzung im
ehemaligen
jugoslawien es gab bestimmte
ideologische gruppen die sich ständig
voneinander abgespalten haben und ihre
grund ideologie ist die die shield apple
auch in einem buch beschreibt der
prophet unter pharao wo sozusagen der
radikalisierte teil der
muslimbruderschaft und produkt die idee
entwickelt hat dass jedes
regierungssystem das mit
menschengemachten gesetzen funktioniert
abzulehnen ist weil es dem ein gott
glauben widersprechen würde weil dieses
menschengemachte system setzt sich
gleich mit gott und der sack also eine
form der götzendiener reiner götzen
anbetung und es würde den einen gott
glauben in frage stellen und diese
vorstellung die hat man tatsächlich im
großstädtischen milieus bei uns in
österreich in verschiedenen kleinen
moscheegemeinden in unterschiedlichen
strömungen vorgefundenen in den jahren
23 10 214 hat sich das stark verstärkt
werden dass vorher sehr kleine
übersichtliche gruppen waren ist es zu
einer art jugendkultur geworden
zumindest es zu dieser zeit des wo junge
menschen die unsere klienten waren 14
aufwärts die jüngste war 13 jahre alt in
diesen parks wo sie sich getroffen haben
quasi über gewechselt sind zu dieser
neuen unter anführungszeichen
ideologischen popkultur wo äußere
zeichen aber auch bestimmte feindbilder
bestimmt ideologische ideen verbreitet
worden sind ausreise versuche gemacht
worden sind und diese leute dann eben
dementsprechend auch in haft genommen
worden sind weil sie sich eben
strafrechtlich relevanten gruppen
angeschlossen haben oder strafrechtlich
problematische aktionen gesetzt haben
die dementsprechend verfolgt worden sind
also teilweise würde ich dem zustimmen
leider auch wenn man das internet
verfolgt
in letzter zeit ist es hauptsächlich
instagram vorher weiß facebook
diese ideologie und die äußeren formen
die wirklich sehr populistisch auch
popkulturell verwertet worden sind mit
symbolen aus der westlichen welt
sportmarken und dergleichen mehr
sogar mit musik ikonen die sujets die
auf platten verwendet wird alles dass es
bei jungen leuten leider
tatsächlich sehr gut angekommen was
wichtig ist ist dass das immer in
abgrenzung zu einem traditionalistischen
islamverständnis stand was wir auch bei
unseren jungen klienten gesehen haben
die besonders viel hass entwickelt haben
gegen traditionelle moscheen und denen
das muslim sein dementsprechend
abgesprochen haben und auch propagiert
haben und müsste diese menschen töten
wie sehen sie das herr schulze wie ist
denn die situation in der schweiz haben
wir da ähnliche tendenzen nicht so stark
wie in frankreich in frankreich ist es
tatsächlich so dass dort in den letzten
zehn jahren eine atmosphäre entstanden
bestimmten sozialen nischen wo das was
wir sie hat ismus nennen zu einer hat ja
heute ist gerade richtig gesagt so eine
art von popkultur in einer bestimmten in
einem bestimmten teil der jugend
geworden ist das haben wir in der
schweiz weniger das hängt sicherlich
auch damit zusammen dass das ganze
soziale setting der muslimischen
gemeinde in der schweiz ein völlig
anderes ist als etwa in frankreich so
dass wir diese sehr speziellen formen
der nischen bildung der sozialen
situation die wir etwa in den bau in
frankreich erleben als ressource gar
nicht so sehr hier haben es gibt
bestimmte felder bestimmte städte
bestimmte umgebung wo man das gefühl hat
da könnte sich so etwas entwickeln wir
eine n was jetzt bei abgekürzt
islamistische nische aber nicht in dem
ausmaß wie wir das aus frankreich oder
teilweise aus österreich kennen das
hängt sicherlich einfach auch mit der
metropolitanen kultur zusammen die etwa
in österreich war in frankreich doch
stärker vertreten ist als ich meine frau
bester hertha hat eben davon berichtet
die jüngsten gefährdeten oder gefährde
auch sind zum teil 14 jahre alt gibt es
so etwas wie ein typisches alter wo
radikalisierung stattfindet kann man das
einigermaßen eingrenzen also eingrenzen
kann man natürlich nicht weil
radikalisierung ist in jeder lebensphase
möglich außer im kindesalter ein
kleinkind das auto aber
ab der pubertät ist es natürlich eine
versuchen sich solchen ideen
anzuschließen man muss das was ich
vorher ausgeführt habe junge menschen
werden verunsichert rein durch ihre
biologische entwicklung sie entwickeln
sich da ändern ihren körper und das
impliziert eine verunsicherung
gleichzeitig haben sie die aufgabe sich
sozial zu integrieren haben eine neue
wahrnehmung ihres körper und einen neuen
status zu erwerben
und das sind natürlich eine phase sie
haben auch in der kognitiven entwicklung
sind so übergreifende ideen wichtig die
gerechtigkeit und soziale systeme da
möchten sie sich engagieren und jetzt
kommt eben die situation dazu wie diese
narrativen diese werden abgegriffen und
zwar mit relativ einfachen narrativen wo
ein 13 14 jähriges mädchen oder junge
dann sich angesprochen fühlt ich will
auch ein held sein ich will auch stark
sein sowie das da portiert wird und das
ist das gefährliche in dem moment das
heißt unsere aufgabe von jeder
gemeinschaft in der wir leben ist
jugendlichen auf eine differenzierte
auseinandersetzung vorzubereiten
wie wollen wir zusammen reden welche
regeln gibt es die ich unterstützen will
wie kann ich mich einbringen in einer
demokratie wie kann ich meine meinung
kundtun und ausgrenzung ist da natürlich
eine schwierige geschichte und das ist
die problematik die wir natürlich haben
in solchen fällen weil es um straftaten
sich handelt und das impliziert dann
immer einerseits ausgrenzung
andererseits vom therapeutischen
sozialarbeiterischen her müssen wir sie
zurückholen würde sie sollen nicht
verloren gehen
und das ist dann eine schwierige aufgabe
für uns herr luca sie haben selber auch
mit ausgrenzung erfahrungen zu tun
gehabt persönlich aber auch in ihrer
arbeit können sie beschreiben wie das
liegt
vielleicht sollte man bei den
jugendlichen vor allem dort wo es wo die
identitäts phase sehr sehr stark ist
kann man nach antworten sucht wer bin
ich was macht mich aus schweizer sein
anfahrer sein muslim wie geht das
wo man sich vielleicht so einen hybriden
identitäts konzept noch sich gar nicht
wirklich vorstellen kann dass es beides
okay ist und und auf der anderen seite
wird man dazu gehören merkt man ist ein
bisschen anders merkt man ist ständig
daran sich zu nicht nur zu distanzieren
wenn so etwas passiert sondern auch zu
positionieren so erklären warum hat das
mit mir nichts zu tun warum hat das
nicht mit meiner religion zu tun das
heißt schon im jugendalter dass man die
die an die stellung eines experten nimmt
um sich dass die sich daran erklären
muss und in der praxis sind solche
erklärungen wie ich bin muslim aber ich
bin kein terrorist ich habe mit dem
nichts zu tun das heißt ständig nach dem
was ich nicht bin so kannst du und ich
finde das ist etwas schwierig weil es
sind jugendliche und junge erwachsene wo
auch die möglichkeit haben sollen auch
andere kennen zu bekommen und ihre frage
in einem geschützten dach also quasi
auch beantworten zu können
und ich denke das ist so ein 1 1 bereich
wo man wirklich schützen muss wo man
auch präventiv dann auch ansetzen soll
es gibt auch in zürich orte
beispielsweise ein projekt treff das ist
so ein mal im monat leiter einmal ich
denke dass das braucht es mehr junge
jugendliche und junge erwachsene dort
können und themen dann einbringen können
wo sie diskutieren möchten das heißt
dort wo sie anerkennung erfahren dort wo
sie ihre identität auch bilden können
und letztendlich auch in sozialkapital
also wenn wir jetzt im bann des ezb-rats
sie haben auch in ihrer arbeit damit zu
tun die erfahrungen der ausgrenzung
sozusagen zu bearbeiten und helfen zu
bewältigen was was ich noch ergänzen
wollte was dann jetzt auch eigentlich
auch zu dieser frage passt ist in der
zeit der pubertät also diese
veränderungen stattfinden wo diese
psychosoziale entwicklung einer
bestimmten stufe eine identitätssuche
geht auch um kollektive identitäten
sozusagen haben wir gemerkt dass die
jungen leute eigentlich die sich dieses
ideologien oder anderen angestellten tag
für ihre ideologien angeschlossen haben
eigentlich das gleiche leben
weiterführen wollen ein konkretes
beispiel zu bringen sie haben sozusagen
beziehungen gehabt group und mädchen und
sie wollten das quasi halal machen also
haben ihnen gesagt na ja in unserem
vorstellungs system ist es so dass du
jetzt sie einfach heiraten hat mir
gesagt das ist aber nicht möglich
weiter die eltern niemals einverstanden
wären wir jetzt da 15 die 14 jährige
heiratet islamisch heiratet und bei
anführungszeichen und dann hat man
gesagt auch innerhalb dieses systems na
ja deine eltern sind ja gar keine
muslime mehr denn sie sind für wahlen
und für demokratie damit sind sie vom
islam abgefallen du brauchst du nicht
fragen und die die kleinkriminelle waren
manche waren aus so bandenstrukturen
bestell betrug einbruch raub und
dergleichen mehr haben da gesagt auch
das soll also quasi erlaubt denn wir
befinden uns in einem kriegszustand mit
dieser gesellschaft und deswegen wenn du
etwas von dem anderen nimmst dann ist es
kriegsbeute und das sei erlaubt das ganz
interessanter so wie sie ihre
jugendlichen lebensweisen versucht haben
in einer in eine kriminelle ideologie
sozusagen einzubringen und genau das ist
geschehen ist auch der grund warum die
leute nicht nur wegen terroristischer
vereinigungen sondern manchmal auch
wegen delikten wie diebstahl und so
weiter angeklagt worden sind und wie
gesagt das gefühl anders zu sein ist
etwas was der jugend eigentlich ist man
findet dann natürlich verschiedene
anbieter und diese leute die sich zum
beispiel in der jugend diesen gruppen
angeschlossen haben haben keine anderen
personen gehabt die sie abgeholt haben
ja es könnte natürlich der jugendclub
sein es könnte was er sich von mir ist
eine hip-hop-gruppe sein wo sie projekte
ins training machen
es könnte von mir aus punk seien keine
ahnung was was auch immer gerade
attraktiv ist in der zeit der pubertät
wenn man so diese jugendcliquen bildet
nur sie haben leider online und offline
sehr starke angebote die wirklich sinn
stiftende inhalte
vermitteln und auf alles scheinbar eine
antwort geben und man kann dann
teilweise die jugendlichen nicht
erreichen wenn man nicht die gleiche
sprache spricht diese ideologie nicht
versteht und dann nicht in der lage ist
mit alternativen oder gegen erzählungen
diesen zu kontern und das ist das was
wir beobachten teilweise sehenden auges
auch lehrer und lehrerinnen auch jugend-
und sozialarbeiter oder auch in den
gefängnissen passiert ist zeitweise dass
man diese entwicklung merkt aber es
fehlt manchmal der ansprechpartner um
diesen menschen auf dieser ebene und bei
diesen inhalten überhaupt begegnen zu
können ihnen auch aufzuzeigen dass man
nicht zu den anderen gehört sondern
tatsächlich teil dieser gesellschaft die
ist dazu bräuchte es aber auch die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den
verschiedenen playern von jugendarbeit
bis leute die religionspädagogik oder
der radikalisierung oder präventions-
sachen machen
psychologen psychiater psycho soziale
entwicklungen daneben auch
zusammenführen in der gemeinsamen
beschau von phänomen und oder von
einzelfällen alles das fehlt ein
bisschen also diese zusammenarbeit um
diesem phänomen begegnen zu können
dieses phänomen wird leider auch nicht
verschwinden sie haben ja auch mit dem
attentäter von wien gearbeitet
sehen sie heute so etwas wäre auch eine
gewisse ohnmacht also unser kollege der
mit ihm gearbeitet hat und diese
personen sind keine einzelperson sie
kommen aus einem bestimmten umfeld
deswegen war es auch relativ schnell
möglich diese person zu identifizieren
weil einer unserer klienten ein freund
von ihm auf den videos erkannt hat die
da passiert sind
wir haben sehr viele klienten gehabt wie
gesagt in den justizanstalten sind es
das soziale dienst der psychologische
dienst vollzugs leitung die ein auge
draufhaben einschätzungen machen wir
machen auch einschätzungen dass nach das
geht auch weiter nach der haft also wenn
diese leute gerichtliche weisungen
bekommen und wir sehen dass eigentlich
die rückfallquote wenn man jetzt von
dieser entsetzlichen tat ausgeht gering
ist wir sehen aber auch und das macht
muss tatsächlich ohnmächtig und wir
haben das in einem interview vor gesagt
wir fürchten es kann so attentaten
kommen denn es gibt menschen die auf
freien fuß sind die von ihrer
ideologischen verhärtung her
aber auch von ihrer psychischen
disposition in der lage sind eine und
tat zu begehen und brauchen auch kein
gewehr die brauchen sich nur in ein auto
setzen oder in küchen mesz zu nehmen
und tatsächlich fehlt es vielleicht auch
an möglichkeiten an gesetzlichen
möglichkeiten diese wirklich sehr kleine
gruppe von personen besser kontrollieren
zu können
um solche untaten unmöglich zu machen
was uns auch ohnmächtig macht sozusagen
ist das problem dass die leute nach der
haft zu ihren alten freundeskreisen
zurückkehren wir wissen auch wo das ist
wir wissen auch die orte wo sie ihre
gebete machen und quasi mit dieser
ideologie wieder radikalisiert und
geimpft werden offline aber auch online
wenn sie natürlich miteinander sich
austauschen über verschiedene chat
gruppen oder telegramm kanäle zum
beispiel
nun haben ja gerade in den letzten tagen
die europäischen politiker und besonders
auch eben sebastian kurz und m manuell
makro maßnahmenpakete präsentiert und in
österreich scheint eine idee fuß zu
fassen nämlich so etwas wie den
politischen islam als gesinnung schon
unter strafe zu stellen
herr schulze worin grundsätzlich liegt
das problem des politischen islam
das problem liegt nicht erst mal beim
politischen islam das problem liegt bei
unserer bezeichnung das heißt mit
solchen begriffen wie politische islam
drücken wir eigentlich nur aus dass wir
nicht genau wissen was wir eigentlich
verzeichnen wollen was eigentlich
wirklich die gegnerschaft zu einer
demokratischen zivilgesellschaftlichen
ordnung ist und wie eine religiöse
gegnerschaft aussehen könnte wie wir sie
benennen könnte wie wir sie
identifizieren könnten
mit diesem umbrella tor mit diesem
regenschirm begriff politischer islam
hat man im grunde keine möglichkeit zu
entscheiden welche form welche ansicht
welche vorstellungswelt sanktioniert
wird sollte und welche als naja als teil
einer demokratischen spielwiese
interpretiert und anerkannt werden
müsste
das heißt man sollte eigentlich schon
genauer hinschauen und sagen können aus
und reiter benennen sagen diese art der
ausbeute und religiöser welt ist eine
radikalisierte ausdeutung und dieser
radikalisierte ausbeutung brot in einem
gewalt
mäßiges potenzial um zu schlagen und
genau den moment verhindern wir durch
gesetzliche maßnahmen was nicht gemacht
werden kann es zu behaupten dass der
politische islam an sich verboten werden
müsse
denn in dem moment wo das geschieht
müsste man entscheiden was dann im islam
so gefährlich ist wenn er denn politisch
ist im unterschied zum christentum wenn
das christentum politisch ist oder das
judentum wenn es und unpolitisch ist
also dann müsste ja doch im islam ein
gefährdungspotenzial an sich existieren
dass in dem moment trat deutlich wird wo
eine politische inanspruchnahme zugrunde
gelegt wird
und da braucht es glaube ich doch
deutlicher der verzierung deutliche
klarheit um auch gesetzlich in der lage
zu sein zu sagen diese art der
interpretation ist juristisch nicht mehr
tolerabel
was riskiert man dann im maximalfall
dass sich muslime die sich jetzt auch
nicht radikale weise politisch
engagieren beispielsweise in einer
schweizerischen partei auf ein ganz
normaler weise politisieren wollen dass
die auch schon identifiziert werden mit
politischen islam frau beste eben genau
das ist das problem
die definition ist völlig unklar und das
dann in einen rechtlichen rahmen zu
packen ist noch mal eine schwierigkeit
die nachweisen der beleg und dann muss
man sich das mit verteidiger und
ankläger vorstellen das ist eine sehr
schwierige geschichte unter strafe
stellen ich weiß nicht ob das dann der
weg ist um einen dialog zu bekommen zu
bekommen also differenziert
auseinanderzusetzen weil das verhärtete
die fronten in einer position zu
verharren
wie sehen sie das sie hatten ja gleich
zu beginn unserer diskussion hier diesen
begriff des politischen islams
eingeführt und erwähnt und scheint mir
sie haben auch gewisse bedenken wenn das
unter graf tatbestand läuft also
nächster stelle wenn ich jetzt diesen
begriff würde und dann vor allem auch im
massnahmenpaket das heißt gleich nach
dem etwas so passiert ist ein erstes
wort das mir einfach nicht in den kopf
angefangen ist einfach generalverdacht
ok weiß was heißt das jetzt konkret
eigentlich für die
für die muslime in österreich und auch
wenn man im westen was bedeutet das
konkret wo fängt es an wo hört das auf
was darf man noch und so weiter ist
extreme verunsicherung dann auch so in
der praxis einerseits auf der andern
seite einfach wenn man jetzt das in
einem nächsten schritt zum beispiel
sehen kann wo kann man dem präventiv
ansätze stellt für mich so die frage
das was jetzt die politik beispielsweise
versucht mitzuteilen mit diesem
maßnahmenpaket ist eigentlich wir kennen
das problem so das heißt wir kennen das
problem das lied primäres bei der
religion da muss man jetzt schauen wie
kann man das noch noch mehr
zusammenrücken
was hier aber jetzt nicht erwähnt ist
was bedeutet das eigentlich mit dem
ganzen psychosozialen
soziodemografischen aspekt kontext
inwiefern spielen individuelle
hintergründe eine rolle und so weiter
das heißt das ganze die ganze palette
die wir in der therapie auch keinen in
der sozialen arbeit und so weiter fällt
hier einfach weg und das ist dann für
mich sehr schwierig weil in der
forschung in den letzten jahren gibt es
auch recht viel forschungsberichte auch
dazu dass man das ganz einheitlich
aussehen muss und nicht einfach nur
einen aspekt tickt und was ist und das
problem auf der einen seite
gleichzeitig möchte ich auch erwähnen
dass wir im kampf gegen den terrorismus
sei zwar seit 20 jahren gibt es auch
maßnahmen und dass das haben wir auch
und ich denke es wäre nicht schlecht man
so ein umdenken zu vielleicht bei zu
schön um zu sagen okay wir haben das
jetzt seit 20 jahren probiert noch
mehrere personen so weiter vielleicht
können wir auch mal einen anderen weg
gehen der in sozialer reingeht in psycho
sozialer und frau besser sehen sie das
auch so wir haben seit 20 jahren
erfahrung mit solchen attentaten in
europa machen hat viel erkenntnis viel
forschung aus dem psychosozialen bereich
aus der forensik aus der
islamwissenschaft aus der soziologie
werden die befunde die in der forschung
hervortreten werden die ausreichend in
die öffentliche debatte und in die
politik eingebaut da kann vielleicht
daher sind auch was dazu sagen
natürlich in der öffentlichen diskussion
haben wir oft eine spezifische
wahrnehmung und spezifische befunde
werden dann heraus gezogen um natürlich
den halo effekt der bestätigung der
eigenen meinung und dass wir dann in
einer diskussion oft nicht sehr
gewinnbringend instrumentalisiert das
denke ich eine bringt das nicht
unbedingt
herr schulze wie sehen sie dass die
befunde aus der islamwissenschaft und
der soziologie fließen sie genügend ein
aus ihrer sicht überhaupt nicht wieder
außer soziologischen noch außer
psychologie noch aus den islam
wissenschaftlichen fachwissenschaften
dort gibt es im google schon ein relativ
breites wissen um die hintergründe die
diesen terrorismus betreffen was doch
bedenklich ist ist wenn kanzler kurz ein
begriff wie politischen islam wählt
deutete damit an dass der islam so
verdächtig ist das in dem moment wo er
in eine politische debatte eingebracht
wird sein gefährdungspotenzial zu tage
bringt und das ist genau die quelle des
ressentiments dass viele muslimische
gemeindemitglieder empfinden dass in dem
moment wo der islam in eine öffentliche
diskussion eingebracht wird er dann als
gefährlich an erachtet wird etwas
ähnliches würde man wahrscheinlich beim
christentum oder judentum oder anderen
religionsgemeinschaften nicht vermuten
sie fühlen sich also so negativ
privilegiert das heißt ihr privileg ist
das negativ zu sein dass sie genau damit
das will das in dem moment genau das
bestärkt wird was man verhindern möchte
je mehr man also von politischen islam
spricht desto mehr generiert man genau
eine ablehnende haltung gegenüber
demokratischen öffentlichen
institutionen wie wir sie gerne hätten
das heißt hier ist die differenzierung
einfach zwingend notwendig um genau dass
ressentiments abzubauen das in
muslimischen gemeinde existiert um damit
auch deutlich zu machen ja die
mehrheitsgesellschaft ist bereit eine
art von intellektuelle wertschätzung
auch den muslimischen gemeinden
gegenüber entgegen zu bringen so dass
sie sich nicht andauernd negativ
stigmatisiert negativ privilegiert
fühlen müssen sondern auch
herausgefordert fühlen beispielsweise vw
hat das sehr sehr schön gesagt worden
sie sollten dabei heraus gefordert sein
jugendlichen zu helfen den weg in die
gesellschaft zu finden ja dann die
muslimischen gemeinden macht das mal
hilft uns dabei das ist ein
gesellschaftliches problem kein
islamisches problem aber ihr habt auch
eine gewisse autorität über eurer
gemeinden also helft ihr bitte bei einem
gesamtgesellschaftlichen anliegen und
diese mit arbeit diese integration in
gesamtgesellschaftliche politik ist
eigentlich die voraussetzung dafür dass
immer mehr dass ressentiments abgebaut
werden kann
das im grunde den nährboden darstellt
für die herausbildung solcher radikalen
biografien wie wir sie kennen denn mit
diesem ressentiments kommt dann
irgendwann weil die selbstermächtigung 1
dh das gefühl rache üben zu dürfen an
dieser westlichen gesellschaft und mit
dem vergeltungs bedürfnis unter
vergeltungstat wird dann stieß und
endlich das eigene heim versucht
umzusetzen
und da gilt es glaube ich auch
unsererseits maßnahmen zu ergreifen die
diese radikale vereinfachung die wir in
der öffentlichen meinungsbildung immer
wieder betreiben zu verändern um genau
damit dass ressentiments zu verhindern
dass sich dann gegen unserer
gesellschaft findet haben wir hier in
europa eine etwas andere ausgangslage
oder eine andere sicht darauf im
vergleich beispielsweise mit den usa
mich hat vor ein paar tagen ein e mail
erreicht von den muslimen democrats also
der den muslimischen mitgliedern der
demokratischen partei in den usa
da heißt es unter anderem wir haben die
pflicht gegen tyrannei auf zu uns zu
erheben und gemeint war dass alle
stimmen ausgezählt werden sollten damit
eben dann die wahl letztlich entschieden
wird dieser dieser einfluss des des
politischen scheint in den usa ganz
anders wahrgenommen zu werden hätte darf
ich ja genau das so sagen ich glaube bei
dem begriff politischer islam muss das
wurde sehr hinreichend gesagt einfach
nur herausgearbeitet werden welche
dahinter liegenden ideologien und
gruppierungen sind konkret gemeint beim
terrorismus ist es ganz leicht weil da
gibt es eine un sanktionsliste mit
gruppierungen und einzelpersonen es gibt
eine terrorliste der europäischen union
und es gibt etwas was wir ähnlich auch
beim rechtsextremismus sehen es gibt
ideologien oder auch gruppen die eine
methode wählen die derart gestrickt ist
dass es
rechtlich nicht relevant ist was sie
propagieren die sehr aufpassen was sie
machen wenn man sich die neue rechte
anschaut die wissen ganz genau dass man
mit den alten konzepten die auf gewalt
bauen und so auf abschreckung bauen
nicht weit kommt auch sie nutzen
popkulturelle elemente wir brauchen uns
dazu nur die identität bewegung
anschauen murdoch versucht
strafrechtlich zum beispiel gegen sie
vorzugehen
das ist gescheitert und wir sehen das
auch in deutschland wo immer darum
gerungen wird soll jetzt die npd
verboten werden oder nicht oder in
brandenburg haben angefangen die afg die
immerhin dort im parlament vertreten ist
im bundesland brandenburg zu beobachten
und der gleich mehr
und ich glaube diese übergänge von
strafrechtlich eindeutig definiert hin
zu den ideologien und zu den gruppen die
inhalte propagieren die in wirklichkeit
antidemokratisch sind und auch darauf
abzielen die gesellschaft zu zerstören
oder auseinanderzutreiben ein wir und
die anderen zu propagieren
ich glaube das soll und muss
herausgearbeitet werden und das ist gar
kein problem für die die mehrheit der
muslime sich auch von diesen
entwicklungen oder von diesen
gruppierungen oder diesen ideologien
abzugrenzen wenn man sich nur vorher
erkennt und eben auch dementsprechend
definiert aber das fehlt natürlich bin
ich nicht ganz einverstanden weil das
ist jetzt eine aussage die dieses ganze
feld nennen das jetzt mal terrorismus
ich will jetzt keine debatte darüber
führen wie man das adäquat bezeichnen
könnte
dass man das reduziert auf eine art von
institutioneller gruppenbildung das
problem ist was wir haben und wickede
hat ist er mit seinem pianisten mit der
atmosphäre sehr schön beschrieben dass
es das was in den köpfen der leute ist
und was in den köpfen ist es nicht
institutionell unbedingt abgebildet
sondern kann sich auch jenseits von
institutionen entwickeln und manche
daten täter der letzten wochen sind ja
im grunde nie institutionell beheimatet
gewesen sondern sie haben sich selbst
eine fantasiewelt erschaffen in der sie
dann gehandelt haben
und ich glaube es ist deshalb sehr viel
wichtiger noch zu erkennen was das jetzt
für spezifische ausdrucksformen sind
also was in den köpfen passiert bei
rechtsradikalen oder neonazis wissen wir
das besser da können wir das besser
infizieren weil wir auch dinara tiere
kennen wir kennen auch die bilder besser
in bezug auf den islam kennt er das
nicht sondern dabei helfen wir uns gerne
mit irgendwelchen schnell gestrickten
schablonen dschihadismus politisch nur
politik politischer islam islamismus und
ähnliches was wir lernen müssen ist in
dieser köpfe besser mit diesen köpfen
besser sozial nicht kommunizieren aber
sie besser zu verstehen um zu wissen als
mit welchen bildern mit welchen
erzählungen mit welchen
persönlichkeitsbildung operieren sie
eigentlich um sich plötzlich als
racheengel in der welt durchsetzen zu
können
und das sind eben nicht institutionen
das sind alles nicht ehemalige radikale
muslimbrüder oder so etwas die wir hier
vor uns haben sondern das sind menschen
die teilweise sozialisiert sind
merkwürdigen welten die die wir hier
kommen kennen wie etwa der attentäter in
paris der vor dem ehemaligen bürogebäude
von charlie hebdo die zwei passanten
angegriffen hat dass er der sohn eines
pakistanischen bauern ist er eine sehr
spezifische vorstellung davon hat was
der prophet mohammed wieder zu sehen ist
das hat nichts mehr mit dem zu tun was
wir als klasse kubismus oder
muslimbrüderschaft oder so etwas
ideologie verstehen das heißt wir müssen
in diese köpfe rein kommen wir müssen
mit diesen köpfen besser kommunizieren
sie besser in den griff bekommen und
alles verhindern was zu einer nicht
sachgemäßen vereinfachung oder redaktion
reduktion der wirklichkeit beiträgt dann
wenn wir das tun ja widersprechen werden
grund der komplexität der wirklichkeit
und damit dann keine
handlungsmöglichkeit mehr da steht
natürlich in keinen widerspruch dass man
den individuellen biografischen
lebensweg dementsprechend bearbeiten
muss das gilt auch für die präventions-
und die radikalisierung arbeite das ist
immer die arbeit am mann und jede
maßnahme muss natürlich telemed sein und
was dahinter geht das gilt zum beispiel
für die attentäter oder verhinderten
attentäter dies nämlich auch gibt in
österreich die chance spezifische
ideologische zugänge über den attentäter
in wien weil es ganz einfach die es pro
packung davor war ein anhänger der herr
sie mieter für die bewegung geben 16
bei uns in wien aktiv war sie
konsumieren ungefähr die gleichen
telegramm kanäle
wir kennen die leute halt weil wir
ständig mit ihnen kontakt sind was aber
noch einmal vielleicht sagen wollte es
gibt verschiedene ebenen auch der
propaganda der ideologie und auch der
gruppierungen die die nicht
strafrechtlich relevant in erscheinung
treten wie gesagt die identität bewegung
die kennen wir auch wir können ihre
telegramm kanäle ebenfalls verfolgen
aber du kannst sie nicht festmachen zb
bei nationalsozialistischer
wiederbetätigung sind bestreiten auch
energisch dass die rassisten sein was
natürlich nicht richtig ist aber es geht
darum diese ideologien die konsumiert
werden von unseren klienten oder auch
wenn die workshops machen in schulen sie
konfrontieren uns mit webseiten mit
youtube kanälen mit telegramm kanälen wo
inhalte verbreitet werden die noch nicht
strafrechtlich relevant und verboten
sind die aber dieses auseinanderdriften
der gesellschaft propagieren die tag für
die bewegung bei uns die heißen tage
sind zum beispiel gegner des oder von al
kaida oder he's not a wir sind 2003
verboten worden in deutschland anderswo
nicht in österreich zum beispiel nicht
und diese bewegung war sehr aktiv an
universitäten und ist es bis heute noch
nur unter anderen namen sie haben zum
beispiel in berlin an der universität in
den 90er jahren das freitagsgebet
geleitet und viele junge studierende man
ein anhängern der hisbollah-bewegung die
sagt gewalt wird nicht angewendet bis
das kalifat errichtet wird wir können
natürlich zu schauen und warten bis
tatsächlich aus dieser ideologie heraus
ein attentäter entsteht wo ich würde
sagen wenn diese ideologie propagiert
werden noch dazu in einer breite wie es
in wien war denn aus der historie
bewegung in wien sind die verschiedenen
extremistischen fraktionen ab ende der
90er jahren entstanden in einer
bestimmten moschee hier im siebten
bezirk sich entwickelt haben und sich
dann verbreitet haben
auf anderen bezirken in wien also es
geht quasi warum zu definieren wer ist
eigentlich gemeint wenn wir vom
politischen islam unter
anführungszeichen sprechen das heißt
natürlich nicht dort kann gar nicht
heißen dass muslime sich nicht politisch
betätigen dürfen dass wir komplett
absurd und das muss wirklich dann
eingegrenzt werden
auf anti demokratische bewegungen
antidemokratische ideologien
weltanschauungen die sehr präsent sind
und wo teilweise daneben auch schon
dementsprechend agiert worden ist die
frage ist wo man dann am ende die grenze
zieht denn es gibt ja auch die meinungs-
und weltanschauungsfragen das
herauszuarbeiten wird tatsächlich eine
aufgabe sei der wissenschaft
insbesondere auch der islamwissenschaft
und zwar ganz konkret die muss man halt
nur dann auch fragen gut ich möchte noch
zu einem weiteren punkt kommen den wir
bis jetzt noch nicht angesprochen haben
emanuel makro hat in einer aussage
ziemlich wütende proteste auch in der
muslimischen welt erzeugt nämlich mit
der aussage der islam sei in der krise
meine frage an sie herr schulze zuerst
mal was für einen eher vater da
getroffen und zweitens ist der islam in
der krise oder ist die krise woanders zu
verorten
herr schulz also wenn ich das höre und
micron sagt mir der islam in der krise
und ich wäre jetzt musste er stolz ich
wäre einfach intellekt welt stolz ich
wär herausgefordert gesagt okay das ist
eine religionsgemeinschaft denn wir
haben eine ordnung eine situation die es
offensichtlich wirklich schwierig und
wir haben schwierigkeiten und wir gehen
diese schwierigkeiten an und wir nennen
das mal so dass tatsächlich wir muslime
und der islam ist jetzt nicht die
religionsgemeinschaft abstrakt das
doping system sondern ist die
gemeinschaft der muslime selbst der
islam ist in der krise sitzt beim weg
eine beleidigung
es ist eine beleidigung in
anführungsstriche deshalb viele muslime
weil eine solche aussage eben über
andere religionsgemeinschaften nicht
getroffen würde und man sich nicht darum
kümmern würde ob der katholizismus in
der krise ist durch die frage der
sexuellen gewalt die in der katholischen
kirche ausgeübt wurde
nein natürlich dass die kirche damit
nicht in der krise oder das christentum
ist dadurch nicht in der krise hier
kommt dann wieder dieses negative
privileg zur sprache und zur geltung und
insofern hätte makro und dann etwas
deutlicher sagen müssen was er mit dem
ist aber auch krisen ein sondern er
hätte deutlich machen müssen dass nicht
der islam selbst in der krise ist
sondern die ganze meinungsbildung die
sich im islamischen welt etabliert in
den muslimischen gemeinden die ganze
organisation der islamischen
gemeinden in westeuropa dass sie nicht
mehr nach dem alten muster erfolgen kann
wie es in den letzten jahrzehnten
aufgebaut worden ist sondern das ist
tatsächlich so einer krise es kommt zu
einer entscheidung kommt in welche
weitere richtung wird sich die
muslimische gemeinschaft in westeuropa
entwickeln und insofern würde ich sagen
krise es klingt gut das ist kein
schlechter begriff das ist der
entscheidung die uns bevorsteht und wir
gehen diese entscheidung an und nehmen
das als eine aufforderung auf innovativ
mit unserer tradition umzugehen und dann
würde ich sagen prima wenn das eine
krise ist den male in einer krise ist ja
auch mit der groner krise so können user
wurde bei ihnen in ihrem muslimischen
umfeld über diese aussage diskutiert
oder diskutiert man überhaupt darüber
über das krisenhafte was das muslim sein
in diesen jahren oder jahrzehnten so mit
sich bringt beispielsweise jetzt wenn
wir darüber diskutieren ich nehme das ja
gerne an darüber zu diskutieren ob der
islam in einer krise ist und war es und
so weiter und das ist so das heißt jetzt
sind wir in einem dialog auf augenhöhe
und wir diskutieren darüber und das ist
genau das was dann in der politik
aus meiner sicht und auch aus vielen wo
ich jetzt keine in meinem umfeld genau
fehlt weil es ist einen bestimmten
kontext gesagt worden in einem
es ist einfach etwas vorher passiert und
jetzt ist zu ihr
das heißt man wirft ein ball auf die
muslime hier ihr habt jetzt ein problem
löst den und das wiederum erzeugt
abwehrreaktionen man aber es könnte auch
eine positive aufforderung sein zu sagen
helft uns wenigstens mit dieses problem
zu lösen und dann muslime nicht ganz
ihrer ohnmacht ihre eigenen ohnmacht
sozusagen zu überlassen ich bin
einverstanden wenn das genauso über
konnte schulz das gesagt hat aber nicht
in dieser botschaft wie das makro und
gesagt hat wie es gemeint hat wissen wir
nicht aber wir tun das was er gesagt hat
und ich denke nicht das problem liegt
darin sich mit dem thema
auseinanderzusetzen das hat die meisten
muslime mehrheits muslime hier in
unserer gesellschaft nicht die
deutungshoheit habe und über jedes land
verständnis und so weiter ich denke
nicht das ist per se dass man darüber
nicht diskutieren kann sondern wer
verlangt was von wem sowas in die
interessen teilen und da haben wir
wenn man das nur zusammenzählt und sieht
welche krisen alle existieren würde man
sagen nicht der islam ist in der krise
sondern religion ist in der krise seien
im moment wo das ritten das ganze
konzept religion in dem späten moderne
in der postmoderne betrachtet wird sehen
wir dass die alten formen die
religiosität und religion gelebt und
ausgelebt wurde immer weniger akzeptanz
findet sondern das neue form von
religiosität auch neue teilweise sehr
skurrile formen von religiosität
entstehen von denen wir im augenblick
nur ahnen was der in zukunft sein könnte
und daher marco sicherlich beraten
gewesen zu sagen nicht der islam ist in
krisen sondern religion ist in der krise
und die gesellschaft hat hier ein
problem mit adäquaten formen der
religion umzugehen
in frankreich wird dann sicherlich in
zukunft die frage zu diskutieren sein ob
der laizismus noch das zukunftsmodell
ist oder ob nicht andere form der
religiösen integration in der
gesellschaft gewählt werden müssten als
die der gletscher sun bietet wenn du das
so sagt würden die muslime auch
partizipativ sich verstehen
aha wir sind ein teil der krise klar
deshalb gehen wir auch gemeinsam vor um
lösungen zu finden und wir sind nicht
ausgeschlossen bei der suche nach
lösungen die auf ein kurzes statement
ihrer seite zu dieser frage was das
problem ist genauso wie bei anderen
begriffen politik ich habe vor kurzen
diskussion gehabt warum werden manche
sachen so formuliert die politik hat die
aufgabe in kurzen stehsätzen und
einfachen begriffen sozusagen zu
vermitteln was dann angeblich ihr ziel
ist oder was ihr standing ist und auch
teilweise wird es erwartet dass es tun
und das machen wir bei jedem seminar sei
es auf der hochschule oder sei es bei
einem workshop bevor wir anfangen den zu
machen waren erst einmal
begriffsdefinitionen weil nie ganz klar
ist wer redet über was ja so der der
etwas in den raum wirft die bei denen
diese botschaft ankommt man müsste erst
vorher definieren und es wurde jetzt in
den statements davor eigentlich auch
gesagt was ist eigentlich gemeint also
man muss dann erst dann die diskussion
beginnen wenn meinte er mit der islam
und
professor schulz sagt zum beispiel die
muslime das muslimische kollektiv könnte
sich angesprochen fühlen und dergleichen
mehr
und jetzt ist aber wieder so das habe
ich auch vor schon gesagt die muslime
sind eben kein homogener block und die
das gerne hätten gehören teilweise zu
den bereichen wie auch so sich die welt
leicht erklären können und damit dann
auch fundamentalistische sichtweisen
rechtfertigen können
also es wäre gut gewesen wenn man vorher
fest stellt was die anderen europäischen
politikerinnen und politiker gesagt
haben wenn so etwas von macao gekommen
wäre
denn er hat unbeabsichtigt oder ist das
statement dass zumindest kolportiert
worden ist er hat quasi diesen
attentäter der dieses verbrechen
begangen hat in frankreich sozusagen
ohne dass das wahrscheinlich wollte so
kommt es auf jeden fall bei einem teil
an gleichgesetzt mit den muslimen die
sich aber komplett abgrenzung von diesen
attentaten weil es gab genug menschen
die als muslime identifiziert werden
konnten sozusagen die dort auch zugegen
waren und gegen dieses verbrechen
protestiert haben das ist sehr notwendig
das geht politisch nicht dass man immer
vorher begriffsdefinitionen macht um ein
beispiel zu bringen wir fragen oft am
eingang eines seminars was ist aus ihrer
sicht der unterschied zwischen
patriotismus und nationalismus und das
ganz interessanter sind eigentlich
bekannte begriffe und die leute tun sich
sehr schwer den unterschied eigentlich
zu erkennen können sie sich vorstellen
wie das dann bei anderen dingen ist ja
also wir haben glaube ich gelernt es ist
sehr viel komplexer und sehr viel
komplizierter als es in der öffentlichen
debatte gemeinhin ankommt wir sind
bereits am schluss dieser diskussion
ich denke wir haben nicht zum letzten
mal über diese thematik gesprochen ich
bedanke mich bei ihnen allen dass sie an
diesem gespräch teilgenommen haben
vielen dank sein ganzes leben lang
religiös und radikal ist auch der gast
nächste woche in der sternstunde
religion meine kollegin olivia berlin
spricht dann mit dem umstrittensten und
gleichzeitig bekanntesten theologen im
deutschen sprachraum eugen drewermann
gleich jetzt widmet sich die sternstunde
philosophie der vertrackten frage der
trias wem es zu helfen wenn nicht allen
geholfen werden kann
bossard im gespräch mit dem schweizer
philosophen
no money no ihnen allen einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]